ten percent of the fuel we use has to
come from renewable energy
a big percentage of that quota comes
from biofuels
great for the environment and
domestically produced they reduce our
lines on foreign fuel imports
meps want to cap crop based biofuel
production to 5.5
of our 2020 renewable energy goals
and promote new generation biofuels such
as algae
but can they really strike the balance
that helps the industry and the
environment
traditional food-based biofuels generate
lots of greenhouse gases and with
farmland use for fuel and not for food
it's increasing demand and reliance on
imports
forseen de jose is an environmentalist
who says reform of the bio industry is
crucial
if we follow the member states
projections by 2020
we'll have the equivalent of an
additional between 14 and 29 millions of
cars
terms of emissions on eu roads so it
seems that biofuels
at least the first generation of them
aren't the environmentally sound
alternative to fossils we once thought
but the next generation of biofuel
technology may be
however it's a complex pathway to
arriving there if
but the industry needs time and
incentive to switch over to new
generation biofuels
there were people who invested in
biodiesel you need to leave them
to leave them time you know to pay back
basically their investments
we did commit a study to check when
investments
for biofuels will be paid back and our
study come
with the end of 2017. the big vote on
biofields takes place next wednesday
but with environment and industry
committees at odds
over the cap on first generation
biofuels could we be in for a bumpy ride
just like these corns it's all aboard to
strasbourg to find out